moody legit opens with nine seconds of
silent black screen we've got balls the
size of Jupiter reading it's not like
they didn't cover the first Hellboy I
know this is for the five people in the
audience who didn't see the first one
this is akin to describing the rise of
carrot top before you watch chairman of
the board you have to be asleep when he
comes down the chimney still doing the
sample when your kid is a red ass
Hellboy freaking nature that clearly up
ends the universe in Santa and literally
everything it had the dawn of time more
reading movie suddenly turns into a much
darker version of Coraline and if I
remember correctly Coraline is already
pretty damn dark golden mechanical um 70
times 70 soldiers because 70 times seven
is forty-nine hundred so neat I say more
who reads bedtime stories while the kid
is brushing their teeth how can they
even hear you properly I'm King bylaws
hot drew heavy with regret what do you
mean isn't this exactly why he
commissioned the Golden Army to be built
to win at what point in the story did we
hear King Balor wanted to win wars but
in the nicest way possible and divided
the crown in three pieces one for the
humans and tooling for himself what
about the pieces for the dwarf Lords in
their halls of stone though so I made
the king who doesn't think the Golden
Army should ever be used again decides
to lock them up deep inside the earth
and keep pieces of the crown that
controls them lying about assuming no
one will ever use it again but you can't
bury evil dude they still found the et
Atari 2600 cartridges silent still and
indestructible my first boner in a
nutshell I thought Khal Drogo killed
Danny's brother this training might be
impressive if it didn't cut about 12
times during two simple moves there's so
much coverage during this it makes me
wonder if the shooting in this scene
took three days he's fabulous are we
holding auditions for Broadway's frozen
cast this mother what he's not
auditioning he's just doing what his
character doesn't a normal Tuesday the
hell
Zoe this asshole trains an open view of
subway trains I'm sure he could easily
kill whoever wants to confront him about
it but it looks like nobody's noticed
why did the lights go out but the
computers only went to static and how
does a computer go to static when the
power goes out anyway because if you say
battery backup then I replied that
wouldn't be static then it would just
stay on the desktop or whatever program
was open goddammit and
what silver Lutz son of King Bella and
I'm here sir
to reclaim what is rightfully mine holy
Blackwood sure doesn't know how to drive
up the price that our most coveted items
don't they none of these people run
Bureau for paranormal research and
defense guarded by four dudes and two
dogs that's vicious they cost me a
fortune and they they show up on YouTube
this guy would later become president of
YouTube Washington they're the wondering
if I this Tambor performance is copy
pasted from the one he gave us and
Muppets from space and now that one is
very good then in black called it beat
you to this tentacles in the background
joke by a good eleven years I guess this
domestic fight between cruel intentions
of the Last Supper is supposed to be
funny but if it gets this bad how has no
one died from the collateral damage of
this romance
she's mad at him for having an
eight-track and honestly a relationship
woes and movies have never been lazier
girlfriend is still on fire though he'll
demons fighting hail demons using guns
awesome
this is basically underworld with more
colour now if Hellboy has watched any
movies he should know that his
girlfriend is officially pregnant like
this conversation is a big plus sign
that's how much of a pregnancy test this
scene is no one noticed this before now
but they do go for the teeth first Oh
hence the name tooth fairies well as
long as they're not the exact same
creatures from don't be afraid of the
dark we'll have a swell original ol time
also why are these tooth fairies still
here why are they hiding
aren't they all over Manhattan eating
Derek Jeter right now Liz that's easy
your extra sensory perception needs to
sign a hit before not once have we seen
these tooth fairies go for the teeth
first
despite AIDS research I mean look at
this guy there isn't even one of them
near his face these tiny things are
vicious and cause real damage even one
at a time but somehow this group is
still not dead but my real issue is the
fact that Liz can literally turn into
fire but she still thinks the best
self-defense course and this situation
is firing single bullets from a gun this
is like Watson firing a gun at the bees
and Holmes and Watson and even though no
one saw that awful movie it's actually a
perfect King analogy but also wondering
why the tooth fairies easily subdued the
one agent and picked his bones clean
while this other dude can
only shoot at them with no problem even
Liz and Abe don't get swarmed then the
guy runs out of bullets and now the
tooth fairy swarm him as if their sheer
numbers couldn't do that before his
cliff was empty this entire opening
action scene is allowed to exist solely
because she waited this long to do her
finishing move I'm not sure if anything
really sinful is happening in this scene
I am gonna send all these same color
umbrellas people brought like the
umbrellas of Cherbourg at a two-for-one
sale on black umbrellas the prince is
about to walk into a council chamber for
magic creatures such as himself and it
remains hilarious to me that all of
their important places are next to
subways as if nobody would ever stumble
on this by accident I must for you
sister oh good brothers and sisters who
call each other by their direct
relationship I bet at the family reunion
they're like brother please call fourth
cousin twice removed to dinner it'll
make youngest uncle on our father's side
ever so happy I can continue my
conversation with my step boyfriend
Congress is apparently going to pass a
bill to add blade to to be submitted to
the National Film Archive and while I
think tell Toros being cheeky with a
movie he directed my main assumption is
that Congress is passing the bill
because Mitch McConnell is related to
most of the characters in that movie me
goddamn even a character with
eccentricities that loves TVs would not
have this steampunk curve TV wall this
is just a cool shot and I love cool
shots but you could have had a cool shot
even if he only had one TV I bet also
some of these aren't even TVs that is a
pink space helmet that just happens to
have a TV inside it you might think
she's anxious about maybe being pregnant
but I think she's anxious about maybe
being pregnant with the Hellspawn baby
with horns because hello buddy did you
hear me say horns every scene with these
evil assholes feels more like a deleted
scene from Twilight or The Fifth Element
than an actual scene from this movie is
annada not noted in Doheny the truth was
that humans would stick to the cities
and the magical creatures would rule the
forest so what happened to that and the
humans effectively end the truce the
first time they tried deforestation I've
seen Prince Nuada
training and killing people and I know
he's fully capable of taking out
multiple enemies the problem is I just
don't get my nose bladed and my sisters
note also bleed it surely that does mean
a thing
just like the blade movies their
Resident Evil movies the underworld
movies and even the last couple species
movies this film gets bogged down too
much an expositional villain splaining
backstory that it's boring I think the
antler King really under spent on the
throne room guard budget or overspent on
the antler budget or both also the
antler King was a the name of my middle
school bow hunting Club be the original
name of the Counting Crows hit song ring
King
see spicy Albanian Cola drink or deep
the name of Barry Bonds medical advisor
now for the final feast my sister you
sure you had one job wink one job I
don't want German no finger prints
it's definitely sexist tell a plasti by
which an ectoplasmic medium such as
doctor crops can control inanimate
things Oh
I mean Jesus if German Peter Griffin
here can temporarily reanimate dead
things then why isn't he used on almost
every murder case known to the world yes
you have but not with me agent amazing
the US government didn't try and contact
Johann Strauss about finding the troll
market before now considering that they
look for such a place countless times
before giving up look I know it's New
York City and there are a lot of people
about but at 3:30 in the morning there
is certainly not a full complement of
traffic as shown here in 1878 a male
chef time design and built these four
crystal diopters that penetrate that
effect and reveal the true nature of
things this movie could have saved a lot
of time with an early Yatta Yatta
warning if all the exposition is gonna
be this useless man Ben Franklin's
national treasure glasses were way more
powerful than Nicolas Cage realized open
it Lucy I will not it's unconscionable
if Johann had a better way inside the
troll market this whole time why didn't
he just say so why not try this first
then see if Lucy would talk this is not
diagonally goes on for some time in
about 10 minutes this will be the thing
that allows Hellboy to win but why is
this grinder thingy here even if it
disposes of trash or whenever it does
this is a clear hazard unguarded just
begging for a troll lawsuit that doesn't
involve patents this time she's talking
about her pregnancy and I'm just
suggesting she would not even consider
telling him about that over a party-line
radio frequency during a goddamn mission
subwhales yeah good god if princess
sister is trying to blend in and knows
showing off her bracelet could blow her
cover
why didn't she simply take it off or
wear some clothes that's just what a
baby would want me to think Oh father
Matt you know that Golden Army thing
that your brother is looking for and has
no idea where it is and everyone would
be better served if it was never found
great idea to find a secret map to it
that only you know about so that you can
find it and see if the Golden Army is
still where your father left it I guess
well nobody will ever follow you or
steal the map so who cares as you were
learning about me I couldn't help but
limit bit about you myself Jesus they're
attracted to each other now because they
both have ESP I can't tell if this is
the lobster too or the shape of water
too but either way there's gonna be a
lot of really weird seafood sex
you mean Prince Nuada discovered
something that can decipher the pronoun
game there are at least three hymns here
but apparently this thing knows he means
Hellboy also what's there any reason why
Prince badass here even needs a sentient
jumpy beam to do his job the editor does
about 75% of it so why does he need any
more allies a giver of life and the
destroyer Oh God almost makes you wonder
why I Prince Nuada even needs a golden
army when he has stuff like this at his
disposal I'm all give me big baby a gun
so badass it needs to be saved instead
of used all the time by all means
Hellboy feel free to move at a glacial
pace why did the elemental even go after
the car what does it see in the car that
it needs to be destroyed but Hellboy can
calmly talk to a baby right next to it
without as much as a swipe in his
direction also of course he needed to
save the baby how else is Liz going to
know that Hellboy who is a terrible frat
boy of a person might be a good father
what the back on the ground he could
have just handed the baby to a number of
people but he climbs up here and tosses
that baby in the air for laughs no one
will be seated during the long slow
painful death of the element the forest
God who was in this movie for a whole
three minutes and we're supposed to feel
some sort of melancholy over its
destruction really not see any other did
he just did I don't even know how you
can misinterpret what just happened but
the movies gotta prove its point about
how characters like Hellboy could never
be accepted in human society so it goes
with the nobody saw anything hasn't
happened angle no matter how nonsensical
that is they're afraid of me what are we
doing that I don't know but it was
covered ad nauseam and roughly 1316
x-men
he's mad why are you with me my college
relationships have taught me anything
and they did it's that girls who asked
this are really trying to figure out why
they are with you just FYI heavy-handed
Bride of Frankenstein metaphor is
heavy-handed
yeah location is a highly classified see
yes but I know of it now which means
that he does too might have been nice to
know before you let them whisk you to
this location and now I'm doubly
concerned about why you took that Golden
Army map out I was a secret location if
your brother can just find you wherever
you go it's your eye I can see your eye
yes
just trying the new look skip Hellboy
taking a shower is the least necessary
scene ever put to film that shower scene
in the bomb movie where Stallone and
Sharon Stone standing up that is more
realistic than this more interesting
than this and sexier than this this
Hellboy shower scene I understand when
the BPRD need to label things like
secret documents and whatnot but pink
towels
Hellboy looks disgusted that he can't
take another sip from this Tecate
product placement bud there are
literally cases full of them in his
locker and another unopened six-pack on
the bench behind it goddamn mother past
time for this when a woman was mad about
something but she's really mad about
something else
you can't ask because then they get
angry Hellboy makes the mistake of
trying his 1980 stand-up material on a
and therefore doesn't get the correct
feedback to try it out in front of that
notoriously tough caroline's crowd if
you heard him you heard the princess
amazing that one guy was in love with
said princess has the final say on this
matter and no one at the secret
paranormal organization run by top-level
g-men overrides it for the greater good
okay sure
Hellboy can't hurt the Prince because
that will hurt the princess but why
can't all these FBI guys surround him
and put cuffs around him the wad is
strong but he doesn't have the kind of
strength where he could break free of
handcuffs he hasn't shown any propensity
for magic either so he's just kind of a
dude right the moral badass but just a
dude you will find the missing piece and
bring it to me why not just stay there
and read your sister's mind until you
get the answer it's obvious nobody's
going to try and hurt you because
everyone wants to protect your sister so
why even leave it takes a steady hand
so Golden Army must not awaken you're
just gonna let him die is that it movies
the needs of the many outweigh the needs
of the few plot line or in this case the
needs of the many
the needs of some chicks boyfriend
accidentally inspires the Avengers
infinity ward's and if ever you were
human that time is long gone I like all
these actors but this feels like a bad
high school play you find anything no if
Abe wants to keep this hidden why is he
pulling it in front of everyone instead
of it just being in his pocket or a safe
somewhere do we really need to know Abe
has it we knew that from the previous
scene the prince lacks the crown piece
and without it his army poses no street
so we have clearance then wait aren't
you going to explain why having that
kind of leverage over the prince will
both save Hellboy and make sure he
doesn't get the crown piece I know Liz
was sold on this explanation immediately
but if I were going on this mission I'd
have some questions you can't take it
out not without killing you maybe I know
someone who can of course you do this
movie keeps backing itself into corners
but always finds a specialist who can x
mark another battle situation how would
I believe that in the entire time this
stone giant thing has been here in
Ireland not one archaeologist has wanted
to dig around this site and accidentally
stumbled on the Goblin City holding the
Golden Army I mean a quick joke earlier
with the glasses but this movie really
is the superhero version of national
treasure oh oh let's take the pale man
from Pan's Labyrinth stick a giant
seashell on its forehead and it's
devised on its hands the eyes are on its
wings you see it's completely different
and not reminiscent of Pan's Labyrinth
at all
to bring about destruction so save hella
boy and it will mean the end of the
world
oh don't save hella boy and stop the
prince from getting his golden army it
doesn't take much to figure out which
one she picks but if he said that the
power of lady boners will end the entire
world give you know Liz he said give him
a reason to live
[Applause]
shiny you bid it though you obviously
bid it for a reason so why is your next
comment about how it looks instead of
how it tastes I was gonna do one of
those skip sins but instead of the
Golden Army must not awaken well at this
point I can hope they don't this movie
is subtitled the Golden Army but we are
literally 16 minutes ahead of the
rolling of the credits and all I know is
someone up the subtitle of this movie
this is why yo.hannes reasons for define
the BPRD and going along with Liz and
the others because of some sort of
perceived leverage is a bunch of bull it
was a plot device and now the movie
doesn't even need to explain his plan
because Abe changed the narrative when
we all know there was never a plan in
the first place what the hell are you
doing if you do the exact same for this
well he's been in a relationship with
Liz for a long-ass time you met the
princess once this is false equivalence
at its finest this is the opening
credits again or did Lionsgate changed
their logo and stick at 97 minutes into
universals Hellboy - not cool Lionsgate
not cool the Golden Army finally awakens
with 14 minutes of film left you
couldn't have called this Hellboy 2 the
smokey German or Hellboy 2 the troll
market or just Hellboy 2 I mean the tiny
albino bat things were more of a
challenge than the Golden Army
oh these robots operate under the same
color-coded evil good rules as the ones
in iRobot oh look these robots operate
under the same survival rules is the one
the Iron Giant I challenged Prince Nuada
right to come back this army thankfully
for Hellboy this is actually possible I
never read a Hellboy comic and I'm sorry
for that but on film this character
confuses me he spends the whole movie
being selfish and using guns and goes
sacrificial at the end but only for a
sword fight which he is awesome at
surprisingly I guess yay Hellboy somehow
has enough room not to be crushed to
death by this gear and its surrounding
compartment I see it right before my own
eyes but I don't believe it
el boy
turns his back on Prince Nuada for some
stupid reason that is unclear and stupid
and unclear also can evil guys man they
can always have a backup can kill bagger
it's like they know in the morning when
they get out that they will be defeated
in a traditional sense by the day's end
so they packed the bitch dagger for a
lame last-minute victory attempt
princess no Allah kills herself for the
greater good and now I'm beginning to
think we could have been spared the last
twenty minutes of this movie what she's
really saying though is that she'd
rather die than date Abe Sapien I never
had a chance to tell you I felt okay it
turns out you can easily defeat the
unbeatable Golden Army by merely melting
the crown so there's that damn they're
gonna have a serious problem getting out
of this place with all those goddamn
robots in the way Ruby steals the season
3 finale of house it'll be great for the
baby babies when the did she have time
since learning she was pregnant to find
out that it was twins again well to the
queen of slime the queen of filth the
queen of putrescence in hey it's me in
the walls it's not a tumor
so you put out a book called the ables
oh yeah 2015 and now you're putting out
a book this year 2019
yeah and it's called the Avis all right
yeah so is it like the same book or what
you may remember some typos and
inconsistencies in the first version
yeah make it fun before yeah I know I
still have that I can't spiel t-shirt
did you know so then why should I buy
this thing you you shouldn't but no god
no
oh hey but the average person yeah
there's pre-order bonuses including a
comic book that I wrote the Jeremy
cinders drawing you know there's hosted
I've already written the second one and
set it off to the editor Oh Aidan it's -
well it's not the title but yeah so
what's the title then strings all right
and just to be clear you do not already
self-published strings in 2015 with the
bunch of typos and inconsistent